und wir kommen zu unserem nächsten fall
dragan katar netz war einer dieser
gastwirte hier in berlin spandau bei dem
man immer gerne eingekehrt ist und dann
eines abends macht er sich nach
dienstschluss auf dem weg nach hause und
wird dann brutal niedergestochen der
täter raubte die herrenhandtasche und
sein opfer verblutet qualvoll auf dem
bürgersteig unser reporter handels
radweg hat jetzt mit der witwe
gesprochen
[Musik]
mir geht es gar nicht gut also damit zu
leben das kann man gar nicht in worte
fassen
das geht auch nicht weg nach 34 jahren
also es ist immer präsent und
einfach ein albtraum ein ein nicht enden
wollender albtraum für für mich wenn
meine familie meine tochter aber auch
für alle anderen die mein mann kannten
es ist samstag der 26
mai 2018 gegen 23 uhr verlässt radisa
katalogen antrag an das restaurant villa
in der altstadt von berlin spandau
der 63-jährige ist teil inhaber des
lokals immer samstags nimmt er die
einnahmen der woche in eine handtasche
mit nach hause zu fuß läuft der 400 m
zum falten sehr platz dort steigt er in
den bus der linie m 37 18 stationen
steigt er an der haltestelle im speckte
fällt aus und läuft 350 meter durch eine
ruhige reihenhaus gegend ist zu seinem
haus um 23 45 ist trageser catan iec
diese ruhige straße lang gelaufen und
direkt vor seiner haustür hat der täter
den 63 jährigen mit einem messer
attackiert und mehrfach zugestochen hier
auf dem bürgersteig ist er
blutüberströmt zusammengebrochen
passanten haben versucht erste hilfe zu
leisten und auch die rettungssanitäter
haben um das leben des gastronoms
gekämpft der täter ist mit den
tageseinnahmen und eine handtasche von
dem mann unerkannt geflohen die bediener
mordkommission gibt nicht auf und auch
über drei jahre nach der bluttat
versuchen sie den täter zu ermitteln und
bitten deshalb um sachdienliche hinweise
überfallen ausgeraubt erstochen dragan
catan ich hatte keine chance die
berliner staatsanwaltschaft hofft auf
neue zeugenhinweise hat eine belohnung
von 5000 euro ausgesetzt
prognosen kann man natürlich nie an
stellen zu solchen verfahren es ist
allerdings so dass es hier um ein
verfahren wegen des verdachts des mordes
geht und sowohl die mordkommission als
auch die staatsanwaltschaft berlin
ermittelt auch je weiterhin mit
hochdruck das ist ein verfahren was eben
weiterhin offen ist und betrieben wird
und insofern hoffen wir dass sich neue
hinweise ergeben für dieses verfahren
auch für katar als witwe ist es wichtig
dass der mörder ihres mannes gefasst
wird das wäre wirklich wirklich wichtig
dass jetzt diese fahndung auch was
bringt und dass diejenigen die das
wissen auch wirklich den mut haben was
zu sagen also ich bitte alle die
irgendetwas wissen und wenn sie auch
denken dass es noch so unwichtig bitte
sagen sie dass der polizei dass mein
mann und uns auch als familie auch in
gewisser weise gerechtigkeit widerfährt
die familie hat eine belohnung von 5000
euro ausgelobt und die
staatsanwaltschaft berlin erhöht diese
summe jetzt noch einmal um weitere 5000
euro und fragt wer hat in der nacht des
auf den 27 mai 2018 im nahbereich des
tatorts oder in der berlin in der
spandauer altstadt beobachtungen gemacht
vielleicht noch mal zur erinnerung das
war damals die nacht des
champions-league-finales jürgen klopp
und sein fc liverpool verloren gegen
real madrid hinweise an die
mordkommission in berlin unter 030 4664
911 7 77